alors fort de ces nouvelles globules
rouges comme l'a dit monsieur
chevènement le ministre doit reprendre
maintenant quelques grands dossiers
comme ceux de la corse du redéploiement
des forces de police et de gendarmerie
des violences urbaines et des sans
papiers des sans papiers qui lui ont
adressé une lettre ouverte pour rappeler
qu'il ya plus de soixante mille
personnes en situation irrégulière qui
attendent un geste du gouvernement
l'explication pascal douce est beau je
pense que la voie qui a été définie par
le gouvernement et celle qui correspond
à un meilleure tradition de la france
c'est sur ce dossier qui l'élevait le
plus volontiers la voie avant son
accident mais les sans-papiers constitue
le problème politique numéro 1 de jean
pierre chevènement
comment pourra-t-il concilier son
appartenance à la gauche plurielle et la
rigueur républicaine qu'il entend
incarner face à des collectifs très
actif soutenu par plusieurs membres du
gouvernement
les centres de latran chansons qu'on
prenne nos contenus appelé à fonctionner
la région et il ya les expressions qui
contenu il ya bref qu'on consomme pas ce
coin est doublée ou on est donc
l'enquêté sur l'assassinât du préfet
erignac en corse
c'est certainement l'une des premières
questions que jean pierre chevènement
devra poser le ministre se fait fort de
rétablir l'état de droit sur l'île il
sait que tout échec en ce domaine lui
est interdit il devra aussi faire face à
la fronde des élus locaux et des
syndicats de policiers son projet de
nouvelle répartition des effectifs de
police et de gendarmerie a été gelé en
son absence il va lui falloir négocier
avec des interlocuteurs intransigeant
onu n'est pas question d'entendre parler
de rodez pas mort pour nous il est
question de d'assurer la sécurité
citoyenne à la meilleure manière qui
soit bon et ça ça passe par une police
efficace avec les moyens à leur
disposition à la disposition des
policiers qui leur permettront de mieux
l'endiguer les problèmes de sécurité
enfin les statistiques sur la
délinquance publiables à la fin du mois
devrait faire apparaître une
augmentation sensible des violences
urbaines
là encore il faudra réagir pour tous ces
dossiers
jean pierre chevènement n'aura qu'une
solution être en forme en pleine forme